♪ ♪
>> NORMALLY THE FISA WARRANT
PROCESS WAS ABUSED, AND THE
REASON WE WANT A SPECIAL COUNSEL
AS I THINK CRIMES COULD HAVE
BEEN COMMITTED.
I WANT SOMEBODY TO LOOK AT HOW
THE FBI FISA APPLICATION WAS
HANDLED JUST LIKE MUELLER IS
LOOKING AT A TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
>> THE SPECIAL COUNSEL AS
INDEPENDENT COMING HE JUST NEED
SOME HELP.
WE WILL GIVE HIM THE TOOLS TO DO
IT, BECAUSE I CANNOT BE COUNTED
ON TO INVESTIGATE THEMSELVES.
IT IS KIND OF COMMON SENSE.
>> THE FBI AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE WERE CORRUPT IN MY VIEW.
THE ENTIRE FISA WARRANT
APPLICATION PROCESS WAS ABUSED.
>> Bret: HOURS AFTER THAT
INTERVIEW HERE ON "SPECIAL
REPORT" AND THE CALL FOR THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL, SOME BREAKING
NEWS.
FIRST UNCOVERED BY MOLLY HAMLIN
AT THE FEDERALIST ABOUT AN
INTERESTING SET OF TEXT
MESSAGES BETWEEN SOME FIGURES
THAT WE HAVE BEEN FOLLOWING FOR
QUITE SOME TIME.
JULY 2016, THE FBI OPENS ITS
RUSSIAN INVESTIGATION, TEXT
MESSAGES INDICATE THE FBI AGENT
PETER STRZOK AND LISA PAGE WERE
HAVING AN AFFAIR.
THEY WERE TALKING ABOUT A
RELATIONSHIP PETER STRZOK HAD
WITH A FEDERAL JUDGE.
JUDGE QUINN TERRORISTS, AND IN
THIS IT ENDS UP THAT THIS IS A
FEDERAL JUDGE WHO WOULD LATER
HANDLE THE PROSECUTION OF THE
FORMER NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISER
MICHAEL FLYNN.
AND IT ALSO TURNS OUT THAT HE
SITS ON THE SURVEILLANCE COURT.
THE TEXT MESSAGES LISA PAGE, ON
THE FISC, DID YOU KNOW THAT?
THAT IS LOW FISA COURT.
WE TALKED ABOUT IT BEFORE AND
AFTER, I NEED TO GET TOGETHER,
AND A MONTH OR TWO AGO, GOT ON
IT AT A GRADUATION PARTY WHERE
BOTH WERE AT, NOT SURE WHO SHE
IS, A GOOD CIRCUMSTANCE TALKING
TO HIM NOT PLACING HIM INTO A
SITUATION WHERE HE HAS TO
RECLUSE HIMSELF, I CANNOT
IMAGINE THAT EITHER ONE OF YOU
WOULD TALK ABOUT ANYTHING IN
DETAIL TO WARRANT RECUSAL.
REALLY, REALLY, I AM IN CHARGE
OF ESPIONAGE FOR THE FBI, ANY
ESPIONAGE FISA BEFORE HIM, WHICH
OF THE DEAL GIVEN HIS FRIEND
OVERSEAS?
STANDARDS FOR RECUSAL ARE HIGH,
I DO NOT THINK THIS IS A
NATIONAL CONFLICT, AND SAYS THAT
HE IS SUPER THOUGHTFUL AND
RIGOROUS ABOUT THE COMPLEX.
NOT SURE WHO IS THAT PROBABLY
THE SOCIAL SIDING WOULD BE
BETTER THAN A ONE-ON-ONE
MEETING.
I'M GOING TO HAVE TO INVITE YOU
TO THAT COCKTAIL PARTY.
HAVE TO COME UP WITH SOMETHING
ELSE FOR PEOPLE TO COVER FOR
ACTION.
LISA PAGE, WYMORE?
SIX IS A PERFECTLY FINE DINNER
PARTY.
WE DON'T KNOW WHERE THAT GOES,
BUT IT RAISES ALL KINDS OF
QUESTIONS ABOUT WHAT THEY WERE
TRYING TO DO WITH THE FISA JUDGE
AND MOTIVES BEHIND ALL OF THIS.
LET'S BRING IN THE PANEL.
BYRON YORK, CHIEF POLITICAL
ADVISER FOR THE DASH AND JASON
RILEY, WALL STREET COLUMNIST AND
SENIOR FELLOW AT THE MANHATTAN
INSTITUTE.
BYRON COMING YOUR TAKE ON ALL OF
THIS AND HOW BIG OF A DEAL OR
NOT BIG OF A DEAL IT IS.
>> IT COULD BE, BUT ONE OF THE
MYSTERIOUS EVENTS OF THE WHOLE
AFFAIR IS WHEN MICHAEL FLYNN
PLED GUILTY ON NOVEMBER 30, LAST
YEAR.
THE ORIGINAL JUDGE WHO ACCEPTED
THAT GUILTY PLEA IS OFTEN THE
CASE.
WE DON'T KNOW IF HE REMOVED
HIMSELF OR IF HE WAS REMOVED,
BUT WE DO NOT KNOW.
THAT IS A JUDGE THAT WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT.
>> Bret: WE SHOULD ALSO POINT
OUT THAT PETER STRZOK IS THE FBI
AGENT WHO INTERVIEWS MICHAEL
FLYNN.
>> AND THAT IS A BIG DEAL
BECAUSE OF HIS CENTRALITY IN THE
WHOLE AFFAIR.
HE IS THE GUY WHO INTERVIEWED
FLYNN AND THE JUDGE WAS ON THE
FISA COURT, WE HEARD A LOT ABOUT
THE FISA COURT WHICH REPEATEDLY
ACCEPTED OR APPROVED A SEARCH
WARRANT FOR CARTER PAGE.
SO WONDERING WHAT IS GOING ON
THERE, AND THE OTHER BIG THING,
ONE LAST BIG THING IS THAT THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT TURNED OVER
THESE TEXT A FEW MONTHS AGO.
BUT THE PARTS THAT WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT WERE REDACTED AND
SOME OF THE STAFFERS WENT BACK
TO THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AND
SAW A LESS REDACTED VERSION OF
THAT AND NOW WE HAVE IT.
SO THE QUESTION IS, WHAT WAS UP
WITH THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
ORIGINALLY?
>> YOU HAVE THE JUDGE WHO
ACCEPTED THE GUILTY PLEA,
APPARENTLY HAD A PERSONAL
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE FBI AGENTS
THAT INTERROGATED HIM, MOREOVER
FROM THESE TEXT MESSAGES, IT
LOOKS LIKE THOSE AGENTS WANTED
TO EXPLOIT THAT RELATIONSHIP.
WHAT IT TELLS ME ULTIMATELY IS
THAT THESE TEXT MESSAGES
ULTIMATELY HAVE PEOPLE AT THE
FBI WHO WERE OPPOSED TO WHAT --
A TRUMP PRESIDENCY AND PEOPLE
WHO WERE PLOTTING AGAINST A
TRUMP PRESIDENCY.
THAT SEEMS TO CROSS THE LINE.
>> Bret: WE DO NOT KNOW WHAT
WE DO NOT KNOW, WE SAID THAT
WITH THE MUELLER INVESTIGATION,
BUT LISTENING TO THE SENATORS
LAST NIGHT, THEY KNOW MORE THAN
THEY ARE SAYING WITH THE
QUESTIONS IN THIS LETTER CALLING
FOR A SPECIAL COUNSEL.
TO ADD THIS TO WHAT THE CONCERNS
ARE THAT THEY LIST AND IT SEEMS
LIKE MAYBE IT IS MORE LIKELY
THAT ONE COMES ABOUT.
>> IT COULD, BUT I THINK IN
GOING BACK AND LOOKING AT THIS
TIME I THINK THE MOST TROUBLING
PART TO YOUR POINT THAT THEY DID
NOT SHARE IT ALL WITH CONGRESS.
THERE IS A MOTIVE TO HIDE IT.
AND I THINK THAT THAT IS ALWAYS
NOW, BEING AFRAID OF THE LARGEST
PYONGYANG INVESTIGATION AS
MR. PETER STRZOK WAS REMOVED,
TAKING HIM OFF OF THE
INVESTIGATION.
AND WE DO NOT KNOW IF THIS HAS
ANYTHING TO DO WITH THE MATERIAL